crece la preocupación de las autoridades
sanitarias neoyorquinas el departamento
de salud de la ciudad confirmó el
hallazgo del virus que produce la
poliomielitis en las aguas residuales lo
que sugiere una mayor circulación del
mismo y lanzaron advertencias la
poliomielitis puede provocar parálisis e
incluso la muerte
instamos a los neoyorquinos no vacunados
a vacunarse ahora el anuncio se produce
semanas después de que se hiciera
público un caso de polio en un adulto en
el condado de brooklands donde al igual
que en el condado de orange la tasa de
vacunación contra el virus es
asombrosamente baja sólo alrededor del
60% se ha inoculado contra la enfermedad
en estas zonas en comparación con el 93
por ciento en todo el país esto porque
ahí vive una importante comunidad
ortodoxa que afirma que las vacunas van
en contra de la ley judía aún así las
autoridades de nueva york- están
abriendo centros de vacunación para
evitar la propagación de la
poliomielitis que suele ser asintomática
que no tiene cura y que se ha cobrado
miles de vidas
y la poliomielitis había sido una
preocupación extraordinaria con cientos
de miles de casos y decenas de miles de
muertes durante el periodo de tiempo
hasta la introducción de la vacuna salk
momento en el que hubo un cambio
dramático de lo que llamaríamos la
eliminación del control y luego
esencialmente la erradicación
jason a finales de la década de 1940 los
brotes de poliomielitis incapacitaban a
un promedio de más de 35.000 personas al
año en eeuu afectando principalmente a
niños de 3 años o menos pero a raíz de
la campaña de vacunación en 1955 los
casos disminuyeron rápidamente